Welcome, mere humans, to my show.
I have risen from the dead to be your host, Cordon Gruesome.
You're in store for six of the most wretched formulas for a mean since your Mother's cooking!
Those with squeamish stomachs should leave now, because...
WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD!!!!!!!
Theme: We are the Wokking Dead! (The Wokking Dead) We are the Wokking Dead!!!
This episode of The Wokking Dead is brought to you by Culinart Productions, putting the craft in craft services.
Oh! On this episode of The Wokking Dead, we'll be eating: Baby Brains!
CZsWorld and Culinart Productions are not responsible if you DIE from eating this recipe.
Nor are we responsible for what happens... to that baby!!
Dave: Whoa, whoa! Yes we are Cordon. You probably got Child Protective Services called on us!
Cordon: Ah, shut up Dave! ...Producers...
Anyways, you'll need these items:
Oils.
Sauces.
Plants!
A sharp knife.
Pork. Wonton wrappers.
And of course...
The Wokking Dead!
Also some corn starch...
But first, finely chop the vegetables.
*metal montage*
Now put in the bowl.
And refrigerate.
Alright, let's see if there's any room in here...
Now you're gonna need some of these things.
Add a shot a cornstarch with a cup of water, and you'll need this.
This is what we use to kill the baby.
Throw the other stuff in the garbage.
And put the baby's head in the mixing bowl.
Alright! Take this, and smash until well blended.
Dave: Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa! Cordon! Are you crazy?
Dave: Child Protective Services is right outside the building. You're gonna get us shut down!
Cordon: It's just a human baby!
Anyways, you'll make little eyeballs out of the brain matter. Brains need oxygen to survive, so make it a super tight seal.
Now set those aside.
And as promised by the title of this thing you're watching...
Then you put the wontons in the wok. Get those suckers in there. Nice and airtight baby brain.
Once you've done that, add 2.5 shots of water.
Two....
And a half....
Now set the heat to medium inferno, because things are about to get steamy.
Ooh! Yeah!!
Now let's remove these "babies" from the Wok.
Alright! Get it in there! Yeah. Yeah.
Cover it with sauce! Augh!!
Now it's ready to serve to the horde. Let's give them a try.
Offscreen: This is Child Protective Services! Put your hands where I can see them!
CPS: Hey! What are you doing?!
Cordon: BRAINS!!
CPS: Get back! I said get back!!
*screaming for help*
CPS: Oh sh--
Thanks for watching the first episode of The Wokking Dead!
Don't forget to subscribe! And if you have a treat you want us to conjure up, leave it in the comments!
Also, try this at your own kitchen! At your own home!
Thanks for watching, and we'll see you next time.